this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by fishing
Clash to most the Mojave Desert looks
like a Barren Wasteland Jagged Rock
swirling sand and scrub brush but the
Mojave is full of life it's been home to
native tribes for thousands of years and
the Mojave is also home to many caves
that hold many Secrets some caves are
reported to be secret entrances to
underground bases and not all of those
bases are occupied by humans other caves
are rumored to be portals to different
places on Earth or portals to different
dimensions there are caves in the desert
that cause even the most experienced
explorers to run away in fear but when
they gather their courage and return to
the caves they can't find them they're
gone year after year adventurers scour
the Mojave trying to solve these
Mysteries some brave souls return with
Incredible stories but others go out
into the desert and they're never seen
[Music]
again human what human oh human get in
herey it's an
emergency look I can't I'm in the middle
of something will you put Seymour and
Seymour down and just get the hell over
here it's an emergency right it's an
emergency fine you you lured me over
here what's with the weird hat oh I'm
sorry pot you can just call me Kettle
what do you want I need help tackling a
problem fine I'll bite what's going on I
grab your iPad and scan the QR code what
QR code hello the one that's on the
screen right now oh that QR code a
mobile game fishing Clash yep a game
where you catch fish what you don't play
face paac and Shooters this is an
ffs first fishing simulator ah that
makes more sense okay I downloaded the
game what are we doing now we're going
to do a PVP battle me versus you man
versus fish mono or finno wait a minute
is this today's sponsor oh caught that
did you thanks to today's sponsor
fishing clash it's a super realistic
fishing Simulator for Anglers on the go
in fishing Clash you can build your own
fishing Village join a clan upgrade your
equipment and catch a huge variety of
fish from all around the world no boat
required only an Android or iOS device
I'm floundering over here some of these
fish are hard to get oh does it remind
you of college you probably need a
bigger Rod will you quit goofing around
and help me out okay sorry sir I was
being Coy you need to upgrade your gear
okay how do I do that go to the link in
the description or scan the QR code to
download the game use my special gift
card code twf and get a $20 value reward
including a unique avatar for free my
welcome code TF gives you some power ups
and a mythical lure card to give you a
Competitive Edge when you're playing
with friends and trying to make a splash
in the leaderboards these are real
bragging rights all right I'm hooked but
uh I got to get Seymour back before he
starts to
ooze well how many fishing puns was that
h a new record all right catch you later
yeah one for the
[Music]
road Kenny Beach had a passion for the
Wilderness but was especially attracted
to the Mojave Desert where most people
see nothing but sand and scrub brush
Kenny saw a beautiful and vibrant
ecosystem and I just came across this
fellow it's been a while since I saw one
it's a nice little Mojave Desert torous
Kenny also had an interest in aliens and
UFOs he lived in Las Vegas and often
hiked the desert not far from Area
51 he also spent a lot of time watching
YouTube videos about aliens and
conspiracy theories one of his favorite
channels was wi files no no the wi files
wasn't around yet but I have a feeling
he would have liked this channel oh it's
not to like check the comment section
they'll tell you uh yeah no thanks if I
want to be insulted I'll just call my
ex-wife which ex-wife you have three
exactly a channel Kenny watched a lot is
serious disclosure run by Dr Steven
Greer who I'm sure you know but in case
you don't Dr Greer has been one of the
loudest voices pushing for the
government to reveal what it knows about
UFOs and aliens one video caught Kenny's
attention it was about Alternative
Energy being researched at Area 51 uh
when they had tested a device that was
supposed to be a new type of energy
source and and they had taken it out
into the range and it had literally
blown up when they tried to activate it
people in the comments exchanged stories
about strange phenomena that they had
experienced Kenny also weighed in this
ain't nothing I am a long-distance hiker
one time during one of my hikes out by
Nellis Air Force Base I found a hidden
cave the entrance to the cave was shaped
like a perfect capital M I always enter
every cave I find but as I began to
enter this particular cave my whole body
began to vibrate whatever it was that
Kenny was feeling seemed to be coming
from inside the Cave the closer I got to
the cave entrance the worse the
vibrating became suddenly I became very
scared and high tailed it out of there
that was one of the strangest things
that ever happened to
me I'm sure it wasn't Kenny's intention
but he created one of the biggest
internet mysteries in history a rabbit
hole known as the M
cave
tons of people responded to Kenny's
comment he went back and forth with
people online for about 4 months most
were just internet trolls which made
Kenny defensive I solo hike across
mountaintops that most people wouldn't
dare go I have been in more caves than I
can count I play with rattlesnakes for
fun some commenters thought he was
making it all up others said it was
probably just ordinary cave and Kenny
was dehydrated so he was seeing things
Kenny was an extreme hiker he often went
on desert hikes with nothing but a candy
bar and a small bottle of water now this
is very unwise and extremely dangerous
but Kenny was proud of his ability to
survive the desert with minimal
Provisions I started at 7:00 but I'm
thinking the sun might be down by the
time I get back to my truck cuz I didn't
bring a whole lot of water and I only
got like one candy bar to get me through
but uh I like rough and it that way but
Kenny insisted there was something
really off about this cave this one
particular cave was beyond anything I
had ever encountered someday I'll go
back and I'll bring a weapon with me all
I had at the time was a knife and a
wrist rocket they challenged Kenny to go
back and find this mysterious M cave if
there even was such a thing Kenny Beach
could not back down from a challenge he
insisted the M cave was real once the
weather cooled down Kenny was ready to
try to relocate K the M cave and as
promised he brought his camera with him
he documented his search on his own
YouTube channel and I'm looking for a
cave that I I found and I didn't have a
I didn't have a sidearm when I was here
before and something about that cave
just spooked me out of all the caves
I've ever gone in this one just made my
body vibrate the closer I got to it the
crazier my body felt and I was like all
right I'm not going to go in there right
now but I'm coming back someday the
online community was thrilled the search
for the M cave was
[Music]
on Kenny Beach was no stranger to the
Mojave he was an extreme hiker Kenny
didn't follow Trails he blazed them it's
rare for me to take the same hike twice
I don't use trails and I cover extremely
long distances it's brutal on the feet I
often will lose one or two toenails
after one of my longer hikes yes this is
what I do for fun
Kenny headed off in the direction of the
M cave and if you watch his video you
can tell that he's pretty confident that
he could find it again it's shaped like
a it's it's shaped just like the letter
M and it's about it's about level with
the ground like like right like in an
area like this so I really got to keep
my eyes peeled cuz I don't want to pass
it but despite his confidence Kenny was
ultimately disappointed well I did not
find the cave I mean I me I thought for
sure I was just going to be able to find
it um I remember it being fairly
easy uh who knows Kenny returned to
YouTube to break the bad news to
everyone who had been waiting for an
update even though Kenny was
disappointed he was still determined to
find the M cave he knew it was out there
somewhere he just needed more time in
the desert to find it I'm going again
this weekend I'll be hiking solo for 3
days I plan on covering about 40 mil
there are many caves I have been in
hundreds of them the M cave is the only
cave I ever feared going inside I really
want to find it again by now the M cave
wasn't just Kenny's Obsession thousands
of people were following the story
everybody in the comments encouraged
Kenny to go back out and find it well
not everybody no do not go back there if
you find that cave entrance don't go in
if you do you won't get
out that was a strange and ominous
comment Kenny even replied asking what
makes you say that but Kenny didn't
receive a reply just more encouragement
to return to the desert so on November
10th 2014 Kenny v packed enough supplies
for a 3-day hike and once again ventured
out into the Mojave Desert but whether
he found the M cave or not we'll never
know because Kenny Beach was never seen
again when Kenny Beach didn't return
from his 3-day solo hike into the Mojave
Desert his girlfriend Sharon knew
something was wrong she reported him
missing on November 14th and search and
rescue teams immediately began combing
the area Kenny's car was easily found so
at least Searchers knew where to start
Kenny had left clues about his intended
destination in the videos and comments
he posted online he pointed to and named
specific mountains and valleys and I
head off in that direction I just go
that direction and that's West heading
towards that's Mount Charleston that big
mountain out there that's that's the
Mount Charleston range Searchers were
able to approximate the region Kenny
would have been exploring when searching
for the mccave helicopters scan the
desert from the air on the ground a
large team searched canyons and cliffs
where Kenny might have fallen
nothing not just no trace of Kenny but
no trace of a campsite or anything that
would indicate anybody was out there a
major break came on November 22nd but it
was almost too obvious in Kenny's video
he spends a lot of time in front of an
old M shaft um I'm going to take the
camera and show you how deep this hole
is and kind of show you around um real
quick um this is kind of iffy I'm going
to step on this thing it's very old but
I'll just show you down inside that
hole that goes way down in there if you
fell that'd be it you'd be a goner when
Searchers got to the Min shaft they
found Kenny's cell phone it wasn't
damaged it wasn't even scratched it had
plenty of battery left it's like the
phone was just placed
there if Kenny had fallen in that M
shaft he could have easily been killed
but cameras were sent down and there was
no sign of him search and rescue now
focused their attention on the area
around the Min shaft even doing a grid
search inch by inch there was nothing
search dogs were brought in they
couldn't pick up a sent
he wasn't bitten by a snake there would
be signs of that he wasn't attacked by
animals there would be signs of that too
there would be blood clothes human
remains but there was nothing there
wasn't a drop of blood anywhere not for
miles it's like Kenny Beach just
vanished Into Thin Air but people
following the story online thought the
search parties were looking in the wrong
place they believed Kenny stumbled
somewhere he didn't belong uh on the
other side of these mountains I'll show
you in a second are the is the bombing
range the Nellis Air Force bombing range
do you know what else is on the Nellis
Air Force bombing range Area
[Music]
51 the United States government owns
most of the land in Nevada in fact it
owns over 80% of the entire State and
corporations Own 100% of the
politicians look at this map only the
areas in white are privately owned the
government owns the rest so Kenny Beach
was hiking and disappeared on government
land if we look at Kenny's last known
location it's not that far from Area 51
now it's fair to say that it's still
really far to go on foot in the desert
but the government doesn't just guard
Area 51 they guard all the land around
it and they will not let you get
[Music]
close if you try you'll start seeing
black helicopters try to get closer the
infamous white pickup trucks will
appear the white trucks will watch and
wait and make sure that you don't cross
into a restricted area they're watching
us up there see them up
there oh that's yeah now normally just
the sight of the white truck is enough
to scare people off but once in a while
someone pushes their
luck
yours are still off
whoa whoa um that does not look like
friendly Park Rangers checking to see if
they need help no it does not these two
bikers wanted to see what would happen
if they crossed the line by just a few
inches let see your hands hands up put
youring hands up I'm not going to tell
you again turn around you couldn't even
count to two Mississippi until the guns
were out then the bikers were treated to
a very aggressive aggressive pat down
and here's something interesting who are
these guys Army those look like US Army
Combat jackets but there's no Branch
tape you'd expect to see US Army or US
Air Force on their left chest are they
military police there's no unit Insignia
or unit patch they don't have any rank
insignia either they don't even have the
American flag on their jackets and most
amazing of all they don't wear name
tapes either who were they they could be
anybody the these guys are ghosts in
this case the bikers were lucky and
allowed to leave but that was a tense
situation that looked like it could go
sideways very easily some have
speculated that Kenny be might have
wandered a little too close to a
restricted area so the search was back
on but this time it wasn't the Nevada
Red Rock search and rescue team doing
the searching hikers survivalists and
investigators started retracing Kenny's
steps looking for clues that might lead
them to the m cave or to Kenny but to do
that they'd have to cross into some
dangerous
territory then about 2 years ago one
YouTuber got a tip from a friend in the
military his friend said he knew the
location but it was on restricted land
this YouTuber took a huge risk going
after the mysterious M cave but he found
[Music]
it when Kenny Beach went missing without
a trace the internet exploded with
theories did Kenny run into Mobsters or
drug dealers and became a witness to
something nefarious or maybe he found a
cave to seek shelter only to discover it
was already occupied there are a few
people living off grid in the desert and
those people want to be left alone but
Kenny was armed even if he did run into
the wrong people there would have been
evidence of a struggle if shots were
fired there would be brass but there was
nothing the theories kept pointing to
Kenny accidentally wandering too close
to a military operation his last known
location was in between Nellis Air Force
Base and Edwards home of Area 51 and
it's rumored that there are many
underground entrances to these bases all
over the desert if Kenny stumbled upon
one of those entrances he might have
gotten himself
deleted a couple of years ago a YouTuber
with the handle abandoned mines 11 set
out to find the M cave and he wouldn't
start at the Min shaft he went right
toward Area 51
after a long hike and following the tip
he got from a friend in the military he
believed he found the M cave the first
thing that looks out of place is the
Stacked rocks clearly Someone piled
those but why there's a bottle and some
old pieces of wood strewn about so
somebody was definitely here at some
point people have speculated that some
caves around the base have doors or
hatches there's no sign of that but
there are some strange scratch marks on
one of the cave walls we get a nice
reverse angle that shows the entrance
really is shaped like an m and it's the
right height Kenny said it was less than
6 ft high when I watched this video for
the first time it was interesting enough
but it didn't feel like the right cave
but then an old piece of metal is seen
poking out from the
rubble okay Area 51 W sted area no no
trespassing use of deadly force
authorized
well I think it's time for me to get out
of here over the course of a year that
video got so many views that abandon
mines 11 decided to go back and film an
update but he couldn't so some new
developments here at the M cave it looks
like they've installed a uh restricted
area sign right there the cave itself
was now a restricted area some people
online pointed out that this couldn't be
the Cave the M cave was becoming so well
known and so many people were searching
for it that if it existed the government
would cover it up they'd wall it off or
fill it in they wouldn't leave the cave
open that's true but a walled off Cave
with an m-shaped entrance M cave Hunters
didn't see that as a deterrent they saw
it as another clue and that clue led to
another M
cave almost as soon as Kenny be went
missing Shan whacker went searching in
the description you'll find links to his
channel and all the others that I've
mentioned today over 4 years Shawn went
on multiple hikes sometimes overnight
and covered about 75 miles of desert he
used Kenny's videos for reference and
retraced his tracks Shawn parks where a
Kenny parked he walks through the same
rugged Canyon that Kenny walked he keeps
the M shaft in sight as a point of
reference Shawn follows the same path
that Kenny took he points out various
rock formations that are clear clearly
natural but then he comes to a rock
formation that looks very out of
place it's not an m-shaped cave it's an
m-shaped opening filled in with a
different kind of rock Shawn finds holes
that indicate there's something behind
The Rock he finds a seam that looks too
straight too
perfect you have this seam that's
running it's almost like this is a like
a foundation almost he feels that some
of the rocks are loose
but that moves which
means this
one right here will move too I can feel
it I can I can nudge it Sean's pretty
confident that he's found the M cave so
for the record the M cave did
exist I think now that looks like a
pretty good candidate to me it's not as
perfect of an M as I was hoping for but
there's definitely something strange
going on with those rocks if you watch
Sea's full video you'll see him poking
around and getting some really close-up
shots of the Rocks but we're still
missing a piece of this mystery remember
how Kenny said that he felt uneasy near
the cave and the closer he got the worse
he felt he described it as a vibration
that was making his body literally Shake
Kenny described feeling fear that grew
worse as he got closer to the cave but
Shawn didn't seem afraid he wasn't
experiencing any effects from being near
the cave at all he seemed fine but a few
minutes
later Shawn was hit with a wave of
nausea he couldn't explain it it came
out of nowhere he tried to breathe
through it
but that cave really doesn't want people
near it get too close
[Music]
and for about four straight minutes
Shawn was vomiting in and dry heaving
the further he got away from the Cave
the better he felt please please don't
don't don't don't show it again don't
show it again I can't I can't I can't I
won't I won't show anymore thank you o i
shouldn't have had those burritos for
lunch now they're not sitting so
well oops pardon me so Sean getting sick
is another clue there's a piece of
military Tech called an active denial
system or ads it's basically a heat ray
ads emits high frequency radiation that
penetrates a fraction of an inch into
the skin and heats it it's similar to
how a microwave Heats food but there is
a way to protect yourself from an ads
attack how aluminum cooking foil a tin
foil hat is a heat rate helmet yep the
level of my genius grows with each
passing
day another piece of military Tech that
could have been used on Kenny and Shawn
is an infrasound weapon the audio
frequencies that can be heard by the
human ear range from 20 HZ to 20,000 htz
anything above 2,000 Herz is considered
treble anything below 200 Herz is
considered
Bas Bas that base no
trouble every inch of you is perfect
from the bottom to the top if the human
body is exposed to frequencies lower
than 20 Herz at high decel levels bad
things happen it can cause nausea
disorientation vomiting internal organ
damage or even loss of bowel control the
note right the brown note is a
hypothetical frequency that supposedly
causes someone's organs to resonate
leading to involuntary defecation
MythBusters even tested this on
adom he said he was uncomfortable but
fortunately he was able to maintain
control of his bowels that's okay
there's already enough crap on TV agreed
in 2016 people at the American Embassy
in Cuba started becoming violently ill
with no apparent cause lowf frequency
weapons were suspected this illness
became known as Havana syndrome the
Cuban government denied this of course
but as soon as the US started
investigating the illnesses
stopped there are even stranger theories
about what could have happened to Kenny
some people say he stepped into a portal
to another dimension or Kenny came in
contact with a race of aliens former US
Airman Charles James Hall worked at
various bases in Nevada in the 60s he
claimed to have had contact with aliens
who flew a Tic Tac shaped spacecraft
these aliens were called The Tall whites
the tall whites that sounds like the
name of a losing basketball
team
what Paul says the US government has
agreements with the tall whites and many
other alien races and these aliens have
underground bases all over the desert we
covered the DL base in another episode
but the story about the tall whites is a
good one too so let me know if you want
me to cover it yes please but there is
another very interesting theory about
Kenny Beach that he's not captured or
missing or dead that he's very much
alive and there's camera footage to
prove
[Music]
it
in 2013 after 17 years working as a
service tech for a coffee company Kenny
Beach quit he wanted to follow his
passions and live life on his own terms
Kenny dedicated his time to creative
Pursuits like art and inventing he even
designed a product and a shark tank
pitch you just pull that put the other
one in and let go and it right now it's
not precise because I used hand tools
but you get the picture it works it
works per perfect and it's beautiful and
that that's it right there that's the
new improved toilet paper rule they
passed on that one he also invented a
glower bear that's the glower bear I
made I designed the can and put all the
stuff on it now there is a
glow-in-the-dark polar bear in here that
I sewed myself and he is so cool and
I've seen nothing like it on the market
this has all the information about polar
bears and the trouble they in so this is
a great idea but you get to see this
when you get to see me these ideas never
got off the ground he tried to stay
positive but without a steady paycheck
he was burning through all of his
savings the redneck whistle now I
designed this not on a computer these
are stamps that I made myself and let me
tell you something when you whistle into
it this thing watch
this woo so loud so cool this is what it
looks like by late 2014 Kenny was almost
broke his house was on the verge of
foreclosure in a last Stitch effort he
tried to sell his house in an an
unconventional way offering himself as a
live-in caretaker to potential buyers
I'm selling myself with the home what I
mean by that is I would become a
caretaker a an allaround caretaker uh
kind of like Alice from the B Brady
Bunch she took care of all those kids
needs and along with the cooking and the
cleaning and and the all the things that
she did um the only thing I wouldn't do
is we the blue dress with Kenny out of
money and losing his home some people
including some of his family thought he
might have faked his own death that he
went off- grid for a while and came back
with a new identity not many people took
this Theory seriously but in 2018
something bizarre happened Kenny
sister-in-law Debbie owns a business in
Las Vegas called the Enchanted Forest
Ricki center it's a type of shop where
you buy crystals candles incense that
kind of stuff in 2018 someone broke into
the shop it's all on camera and the guy
who broke in it looks like Kenny it was
a strange Breakin the only thing he
stole was an iPad on his way out the
door Kenny's mother Susan is convinced
it's him is it Kenny it's really hard to
tell Kenny's mother says it is Kenny's
daughter Victoria says it might be
Debbie and most other people including
the police don't think it's him but most
of Kenny's family think that it's
possible Kenny is still out there
somewhere that the financial stress was
becoming too much the failure of his
inventions was demoralizing so he packed
up some gear and headed out to the
Mojave Desert and from there started a
new life they believe he intentionally
left his cell phone by the Min shaft so
he couldn't be tracked the people
posting on Kenny's and other YouTube
channels didn't buy it Kenny was such a
positive guy he wouldn't just leave he
has a daughter he had people in his life
that loved him MK fans just wouldn't
accept that Kenny would intentionally
disappear they believed he went out and
in search of the M cave just like he
said he would but as the investigation
into Kenny Beach continued followers of
the story got some Grim news when Kenny
left for the desert that morning he
didn't take his camera with him but he
did take his
gun the mystery of Kenny Beach and the M
cave is one of the most requested topics
on this channel Kenny disappeared almost
10 years ago but the story still
fascinates people including me the story
has everything The Lure of the unknown
the M cave there is an element of danger
the extreme conditions of the desert
that put Kenny and anyone who followed
him in constant risk but how much of
this mystery is true are there things
that we can debunk well there are but
there still are a lot of questions
that's another reason the story endures
there's no closure there's no resolution
until we get answers this mystery will
continue to Captivate so what do we know
were any of the caves we looked at today
the M cave well there's no way to tell
the people who discover those caves say
yes they followed Kenny's directions to
the letter but even Kenny contradicts
himself a little and it's about as tall
as I am and kind of narrow and uh it's
stuck on the side of a mountain and it's
about it's about level with the ground
like like right like in an area like
this so is the m cave stuck on the side
of a mountain or is it on ground level
if it's ground level Kenny walked right
past it and didn't notice look at this
shot from Kenny's video now this shot
from Sha's video that's the same rock
formation if that's the M cave even if
it was covered up wouldn't Kenny have
noticed it I would think so but maybe
not he's not experiencing any vibrations
or the effects he described earlier so
maybe he just didn't notice Shawn found
the cave in 2018 Kenny was there in 2014
and possibly earlier if that cave was
intentionally covered by the time Shawn
got there it had been covered for Years
also if there was technology near the
cave that was making Shawn sick that
Tech wasn't operating when Kenny walked
by he stopped for a bit right in front
of that rock formation he didn't mention
feeling anything as for the break-in
video Kenny's mom says it's him but it
isn't that footage has been run through
facial recognition software it's been
examined by experts that's not Kenny
Kenny's girlfriend Sharon tries to offer
some closure but it's not good
[Music]
news Kenny had struggled with depression
for many years but he didn't want to
talk to a therapist or try medication he
told Sharon that depression is like
losing an arm you just get used to it in
the months leading up to his
disappearance Sharon noticed that Kenny
was getting getting more withdrawn and
seem sad understandable considering his
financial struggles and failing
businesses eventually Kenny told Sharon
that his father had taken his own life
and he never really healed from it when
police searched Kenny's computer they
discovered he was reading a lot of dark
topics about how to hurt himself they
also found an eerie and sad document
Kenny had written help me over and over
and over again Sharon believes Kenny
went out into the desert with no
intention of returning she believes he
left his cell phone so he couldn't be
tracked he then found a cave in a remote
part of the desert and never came out if
that's true it's such a sad ending to
one of the best modern Mysteries but
other people in Kenny's family
especially his daughter Victoria resist
the theory Kenny had such a vibrant
adventurous Spirit to take his own life
would be extremely out of character also
even though Kenny had burned through
most of his savings on his inventions he
wasn't in a lot of death he was
intelligent personable and had a wide
variety of skills it would have been
easy for Kenny to find work if he wanted
to but Sharon said he never wanted to
work for anyone again and Kenny also had
a support structure his mother his
brother his daughter and Sharon they
were all there for Kenny he never had to
be alone if he didn't want to be but
depression can be crippling I have my
own bouts with it nowhere near as severe
as Kenny but I've had days where it was
almost impossible to get out of bed so I
understand why Kenny kept this to
himself it's embarrassing he was
Fearless in the wilderness but there was
a part of his personality that was
helpless I'm embarrassed revealing my
own struggles with depression I wrote
this part of the script five times and
deleted it four times but I'm keeping it
in because if you're struggling I want
you to know that you're not alone one in
five people report depression symptoms
at some point in their lives and that
number is going up this is why the story
of Kenny Beach endures yes it has the
mystery the D danger and all the
conspiracies but at its core the story
of Kenny be is a story about a man who
lived a simple life but wanted something
more he tried and failed then he tried
again and failed again and every time he
reached out life beat him back he lost
everything and tried again I can relate
to this can't you the story of Kenny
beich is the Story of All of Us
sometimes life feels like an endless
string of failures and disappointments
but you have to keep trying there's that
old saying when you're going through
hell keep going and there are people out
in the desert right now searching for
Kenny they go out every day and every
day they fail but they wake up the next
morning and they go out and they try
again I have a ton of respect for these
people they don't care about the M cave
they care about Kenny and they believe
like I do it's time for Kenny to come
[Music]
home
thanks to fishing Clash for sponsoring
today's video go to the link in the
description and don't forget to use my
code twf for $20 worth of free gifts
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's aish I'm
all about that base baby this has been
the wi files if you had fun or learned
anything do him a favor like subscribe
comment share that stuff really helps us
out like most topics we cover on the
channel today's topic was recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the Wi
files.com tips and remember the yfiles
is also a podcast twice a week I post
deep dives into the stories we cover
here on the channel I also post episodes
that wouldn't be allowed on the channel
it's called the wi files operation
podcast it's available everywhere you
get your podcasts and if you need more
wi files in your life check out our
Discord there are thousands of people on
there 24/7 and they're into the same
weird stuff we are it's a great
Community it's a lot of fun and it's
free to join and special thanks to our
patrons who make this channel possible
every episode of the wi files is
dedicated to our patreon members so I I
don't deserve the tremendous support
that you give but I am truly grateful
for it and if you'd like to support the
wi files consider becoming a member on
patreon fors a little L three bucks a
month you get access to perks like you
get to see the videos early with no
commercials you get access to merch only
available to Members Plus you get two
private live streams every week just for
you another great way to support the
channel is grab something from the wifi
store grab yourself a heck of his
T-shirt or a fishable coffee mug or a
hoodie or one of these squeezy stuffed
animal heck of fish tuck and plushy fish
toys that's going to do it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are
[Music]
appreciated oh oh oh oh
yeah I play Bia scaria 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing the like I
sh but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it never ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's home with MK truck I being
only true
aw did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish on thday night
WN all through the
night all I ever wanted was to can hear
the truth to the W I'm all through the
night
[Music]
the M man SIDS and the solar storm still
come to a go the The Secret City under
ground mysterious number stations Planet
are to project Star Gate and where the
dark Watchers
[Music]
found a
simulation the Black Knight satellited
told me so I can't believe I'm dancing
with the
fish fish on thday night
they the
night all I ever wanted was to he the
truth to the W B IAT all through the
night head F Thursday night Wednesday J
and all through the
night all I ever was to just hear the
truth so the feet all through
the
love love to dance good love to dance
good love to dance good L to
dancee lovees to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and C love to
dance when the feeling is right on in
time good
[Music]
love
yeah